اول حاجه هذه الرهانات ليست حتميه وهي
مربوطه جدا كذلك
بمدى تفاعل الفاعلين واصحاب القرار ويمكن
تغيير من تغيير من وضع هذه همم الرهانات
حسب القدره ولكن الذين راها اليوم ولو
بناخذ
المستوى المناخي وهمم والملاحظ ان خصصنا
تقريبا عشرات من الدولارات
لهذا الريال ولكن العديد من المواصفات
وحقيقه تعديل الطريق الذين سيروا فيه همم
والحاجه الثانيه ان هذه الرهانات لا يمكن
النظر اليها كريه هناك
يعني
وتاتي في في حاله كذلك ازمه وصفناها في
الاسئله
همم ولكن
التشابك هذه الرهانات تؤدي الى معناها
مبيعات تكون اكبر واسرع على البشريه كامله
للرجوعلك انا حسب راينا هناك بعض من
الناحيه المبدايه لازم تصليح بعض المفاهيم
ثم عمليا هناك تقريبا ثلاثه او اربع محاور
ممكن نشتغل همم
هذه الازمه اصبحت يعني عندها تكاليف كبرى
وما تكاليف مخفيه على العالم كله وانه
تاخير التاخير في الحلول سيكلفنا اكثر
وسيكل ابناءنا اكثر مصاريف واكثر تكاليف
نهائي
الفكر المالكي والفكر المالي الذي طه على
الفكر الاقتصادي وفكره
توزيعها العادي للثوره
وظائف معروفه اربعه وخمسه وظائف كوبرا هو
الوسيله واعداد ولا يمكن ان يكون هو الهدف
الهدف خلق ثروه والانتاج والتوزيع الانتاج
والمردوديه وما الى ذلك الحاجه الاخرى
الذي يجب اصلاح كذلك كل هذه ال ال ال ال
ال ال الاموال التي البعيده والغير
المراقبه
والتكاليف المخفيه هناك العديد من
التكاليف المعرفيه التي لامها تحدث عليها
في في مواضيعنا مثل همم وممكن ياخذ مثاليه
المثال الاول هو المناخير المثال المناخي
لماذا وصلنا لهذه الحاله لانه لمده سنوات
وعقود هناك البعض وفي بعض المناطق لو
يسوون هناك تكلفه على المناخ ولم ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار هذه التكلفه في في همم في
في كل فتره الانتاج وفي البيع و لماذا
نتحملوها جميعا لانه هناك لم نكن نقدم
وتكلفه مخفيه اخرى يعني
زياده في النسب المديريه العديد من البنوك
الكبرى المركزيه هي لها تاثير مباشر على
الميزانيات وعلى مديونيات همم الديون
العديد من الدول ذات الاقتصاديه المتوسطه
وضعيفه هذه كلها اشياء مخفيه يجب حسابه
القراءات الحسابات الحساب لها ويجب
دراستها ويجب وضعها على الطاوله للمزيد من
العدل هذا هو المطلوب